[Music]
[Applause]
uh jeff zerebeck
is the senior staff writer for the
athletic he covers the ravens he joins
us now jeff thanks for joining us
where are the ravens players right now
ravens players are at home but they'll
have the hope is
that they'll have a practice later today
and one another walk through practice
which would be a second straight day
with the walk through and then at least
the tentative plan tonight
is to fly out to pittsburgh uh you know
and to continue preparations for the
game tomorrow afternoon but
of course that's all you know pending
because
they're gonna have to wait uh to see if
there's any positive tests
uh from this morning's batch of tests
and they're now at nine straight days
with positive tests in that building so
that's hardly a given that there won't
be and there was no chance lamar jackson
was
going to be able to play yeah no you
know he's he's in the middle of a 10 uh
you know a 10-day isolation after he
tested positive over the weekend
um the hope is that he will have enough
time to be back for uh
you know the dallas game which was moved
to next tuesday now
i uh i heard from a source this morning
and i want to bring this to your
attention
about um what has gone on with uh
the ravens and uh this came from a
league source
uh last night saying that uh because i
said did the ravens feel like they're
being picked on
and uh what i got was classic hypocrisy
uh they won't be vigilant about the
protocols in the front end
john harbaugh cries he's being screwed
on the back end for consequences of said
violations his coaching staff was
responsible for the outbreak there what
do you make of that comment
well you know there's still work being
done
to figure out how you know the entry
point in the building
uh but obviously there's a lot of focus
on the strength and conditioning coach
the ravens disciplined him um and
suspended him
for a while and we'll see about that but
yeah obviously when you have this many
cases uh and we're talking about over 30
now in the building
uh you know not just counting players
we're talking about support staff
you have to wonder whether the protocol
was all being
followed and the ravens had said a lot
this year
about how comfortable they were with
their protocol and how much money and
time they invested in it
and now they've had the team with the
biggest uh you know they've been the
team with the biggest outbreak in the
nfl so there's obviously some
questions there uh that they're going to
have to answer
um in terms of whether they're following
protocol and what they were and we're
not doing
i'm trying to separate fact from fiction
as well when it comes to the story with
the ravens
uh was there the possibility of a
wildcat strike
of the ravens was that was that topic
broached by the team
i know there was some players that were
uh you know
weren't willing to play they did not
want to play tuesday and they made it
clear
and that kind of started on sunday you
know sunday afternoon
uh they had a virtual meeting with uh
nfl chief
medical guru dr alan sills
and it apparently was pretty tense and
players made clear they weren't happy
with how some
certain situations were being handled uh
they were particularly disappointed
and kind of you know frustrated with the
lack of the media test on game day
mornings i mean this is kind of
you know they had multiple positive
tests on november 22nd to mourning the
titans game
but all those people are on the field
and were on the sideline because they
didn't have the test results between
later that night
so it was pretty tense there um you know
and
they all weren't buying what uh dr
stills was saying they were kind of
disappointed with some stuff
and and then the disappointment grew the
next morning when they
reported to practice and they were sent
home again uh because the league wasn't
ready to have them practice so yeah
they're playing and then they had a
players only meeting where they kind of
decided that
look we're not playing on uh you know
we're not willing
jeff i'm confused shouldn't the steelers
be upset
not the ravens well obviously the
steelers should be upset
you know what i mean they've now been
innocent bystander in two of these
situations
uh but uh the ravens also you know have
safety concerns from their end too
about the whole thing but obviously
depending on
whether the how this was brought into
their building
you know there's definitely a case could
be made that uh you know they're
at fault for a lot of this how big of a
disappointment are the ravens viewed
in baltimore and how they handle this
no no they're just their performance on
the field oh yeah there's been a lot of
frustration uh dan i mean it's just
you know they had high expectations this
year and uh
you know starting with the offense that
really hasn't been productive all year
but very inconsistent
obviously the the perception is
quarterback mark jackson has taken a
step back
uh they haven't played well they've been
uh you know in a lot of big games so
yeah definitely i mean before you know
the loss of the titans
sort of uh increased the frustration
with the team and ever since we've had
you know the covet outbreak but i'm also
wondering about lamar jackson did he
take a step back or did defenses take a
step
forward i think it's a combination of
everything i mean they talked a big game
all off season about needing to evolve
offensively um because they knew
defenses were gonna have a better handle
on what they were doing and
they just haven't done that they just
haven't been able to adjust to what
defenses have been doing
i mean some of it's on personnel the
offensive line has taken a step back
that hasn't helped jackson
uh they don't have a top-notch receiving
core
but jackson's also missed some throws
and he has been unable to
uh you know unlock the downfield passing
game and he just hasn't been as
confident
or as uh you know sharp or as efficient
as he was last year so
there's plenty of blame to go around but
jackson definitely has to have
accountability in it
and how is this offense different with
rg3 running it instead of lamar jackson
i think it's going to be a similar
offense but obviously you don't have you
know
the athleticism and the dimension uh you
know that
you know lamar jackson brings he's one
of a kind in that area
but our robert griffin's plenty capable
the issue is you know their offensive
line is a mess right now
they probably will start a center who's
never played in the nfl before
in terms of offensive line they don't
have their full back they don't have
their blocking tight end
so they're kind of a mess throughout the
personnel um but i'm sure they'll try to
keep their offenses similar as possible
and our robert griffin's beaten the
steelers before i know it's a different
situation last year
but uh they'll be capable you know
they'll be capable of moving the ball
but they definitely have a lot of
hurdles to overcome in terms of all the
absences
lamar jackson sensitive with the media
at all with criticisms this year
no you know he's you know it's always
been tough this year dan with the whole
zooms you know we haven't been in the
locker room we haven't had in-person
press conferences
so it's always hard to say how players
are reacting but
he's been pretty similar to what he was
last year i mean he has expressed
you have seen him express more
frustration on the field
you've seen a couple of uh you know
animated conversations that you didn't
really see last year
uh but i imagine that all comes with the
frustration of not playing as well and
the team losing
he's not traveling with the team no okay
no no i mean the the question is the the
one day delay
really it affects potentially two
players uh jk dobbins and mark ingram
their self-isolation ends uh today
uh they're ten days so they
theoretically could fly
tomorrow to pittsburgh and they're gonna
have to do it early to get in turn for
the 340 kickoff
and they could play but that's going to
be a decision
they're going to have to make if you
want two guys who haven't played
practice in 10 days
to kind of just jump right on the field
and play thank you jeff you certainly
have a lot to
write about there hopefully we get this
game in we appreciate your time and
thanks for joining us again
thanks for having me that's uh jeff
zerebeck a senior staff writer for the
athletic covering the ravens